And then what I, you know, what really bummed me out. I was thinking about this,
th th th th this past week,
like I was thinking about high school, I was thinking about,
I was thinking all school, not just high school.
I think about my elementary school. I was about high school.
I was think about all the things that I've done in my life.
And I was thinking about them fondly. Like I was thinking about like,
mostly like how it was fun. And then I thought about how I,
how did I feel though, when it was happening?
And a lot of the time I felt not happy. I felt like,
like in high school, it's a very awkward time, you know, or you're growing up.
You're like, Oh, I wasn't, I wasn't, you know, I didn't,
you didn't feel comfortable. You didn't feel whatever it was,
you felt out of place. And, uh, and I thought, well,
that's interesting that now I look back on that fondly and it
makes me happy to think about that time. When in actuality,
it wasn't necessarily, it wasn't necessarily the happiest of times. Right.
So I thought about how retrospect kind of like candy coats, everything.
And then I was thinking about all the things in my life
that I want to do, and I was getting excited for them,
you know, whatever it is, having a family doing my next, next, next, Netflix,
special, um, you know, uh, uh,
whatever it is, lunch even tomorrow. Oh,
I get to have a lunch tomorrow at the place I like, uh,
or I'm going to Las Vegas in three weeks.
I can't wait to hang with my buddies and try to up jump the buggy, you know?
And I was ex and I was thinking about all the things I was excited about.
And then I was thinking about doing all of those things, like,
think about going to Vegas with your friends. Think about getting to do that.
Think about if next week you and your buddies got to go to Las Vegas without
your wife, without your girlfriends, or if you don't have one,
it doesn't matter.
Maybe you going to go plucking and up jump the boogie with your friends. Okay.
You'd be so excited.
Wouldn't you you'd be so excited to just go let off some steam. Now,
what we know is if you're over 30.
It.
Wouldn't be as good as you made it out. What you thought it was going to be,
because that's what happens. You go. Yeah, let's do this.
And you go and you get to the club in Vegas or whatever it is. And you're like,
Oh, it's okay. We go to the strip club and you're like, Oh, I thought it was,
maybe it was going to meet a chick.
And maybe I was going to start dating a stripper and it didn't happen.
You let your fantasy go run wild, but that's what keeps you going.
Hell my point is,
is it's never as good as you.
You think it's going to be and retrospect, candy coats, everything.
So that means the worst time is
now. That sucks.
Dude. If,
if looking back on things that weren't necessarily good,
make it better. And if you're excited for something,
that's not going to be as exciting as you.
Think it is, then the worst.
Time is now.
And that's all you ever have now
we're. Say, Oh good. We're.
Let's all live in it together. It sucks the most.
Now
it sucks the most. Now I can't, I can't stop it.
I can't, I can't even stop it. I'm.
Yes. I always want the thing to be a kill switch. And it's not.
Yes.
I was wanting to start something when I hit the key and then have it be a kill
switch. Yes. And it never is. It just starts to fall over when the summer,
again, be much funnier to cut it out.
But when fire does a set up that way, I always talk to him.
boy. Yes.
Um, yeah. So that's it. That was the profound thought I had today.
At least you get to look forward to things that won't be that good.
You know what I'm talking about, but sometimes the surprise you, right?
When the pops off, when you really do up jump the boogie. Right. But it's never,
when you expect it though,
remember those times you were just driving around in the Valley with your old
roommate and and you were like, eh, whatever. And then something happened,
Uh, like, uh, you know, like some cool happened and you were just like,
Whoa. Yeah, dude. I didn't know that. That was going to be awesome.
And then it happened, man. It's all good.
Actually that guy, I remember my old roommate, my old roommate
and his buddy who I'm still friends with now,
he now, now his buddy is one of my, really, really good friends.
You know how that always happens. You're like,
you think you have a friend and then you meet their friend and then you guys get
closer. And you're like, Oh, that's the real friend anyway.
So I met that guy and we still keep in touch. Yeah.
I still keep in touch with the other guy too. But uh,
I used to do this thing with like waiters and,
or anytime someone will give you something like if you were like at a mail place
and they were to,
you were to mail something and they'd give you a receipt or whatever I used to,
I used to do this thing for me. This is how dorky I am. Instead of saying,
thanks, man. I'd say, I'd say, I'd say, I'd say X-Men,
but I would do it. And they would never, they would never, you know,
they'd never catch on because either there's two things that were going to
happen. They're either not going to hear it. Cause they're so ready to hear.
Thanks man.
So say X-Men and they think are,
or so they either think they either just here, thanks man.
Or they hear me say X-Men and they think, well,
he obviously didn't say X-Men I misheard it.
So I'll just let it go.
So we were at this restaurant house of pies in a w in
Hollywood, you know? And I was telling my buddies about this,
how I say X men sometimes. And it's funny for me. And he was like, really?
And I said, yeah, I said, guys, come by and drop the food off as like, Oh,
X men. And they say, no problem. Cause I'm,
obviously not in their head saying X-Men but so my buddy Mitchell is like,
Oh, all right, I'm going to try it. And I was like, all right, cool.
And I was like, listen, you can't say X-Men like, it's thanks, man.
Like, you can't be like X man. Like that's. You got to say X men.
You don't have to be like X-Men, but you gotta be like,
X-Men you gotta be like X-Men.
So the waiter drops the food off. And my buddy says.
Excellent. And the waiter says,
did you say X-Men
bro?
I don't know if there's ever been anything funny or that's happened.
Like I had been doing it for years nobody's ever,
and he just goes eczema. And the waiter says, did you say X-Men?
Oh, for sake, man. And.
He was like, Oh no, I don't know.
Imagine.
Big X-Men to nobody yet. You'd be like, what, what?
As far as the losing it's also even better.
Cause like the X-Men movies weren't even like popping yet.
Like it was just like a thing that dorks wouldn't know about it wasn't like
Marvel was so big.
He's just X-Men for no reason when he gets a waffle.
Dude, I love like that, man. I love like that.
Oh. I was had my hands,
like in my with my knees together.
Rolling around on that pleather booth.